My brother in law had a metal plate put
in his shoulder because his collar bone
was shattered in a motorcycle accident.
Was going to say it's either like
motorcycles or skiing or like any,
any anything where you're going
over 30 miles an hour slam.
That's the only way to
break a collar bomb.
There's no other way to fake collarbone.
Yeah, cause he's, cause he's got it drawn.
Get hit by a car or motorcycle crash.
It's like why I'm saying, oh he wiped out.
Wiped out. Dude. I saw a guy get
hit the other day and it made my,
made my heart hurt for the cake.
Yeah, he got smoked. I watched it.
I watched it happen.
He was key,
was going left her in their
section and a guy ran the yellow,
but he was really running a red, it
was red, you know what I mean? And,
and he slammed on the brakes and the car
turned a little bit and the bike and he
tried to like jerk the bike
as hard as he could, but boom.
And it made my heart he was alive, but I
was just like, oh, probably broken. Oh,
he was, oh dude, he couldn't, he
didn't move. I mean, fuck yeah.
Motorcycles are so scary.
The shit out of me, man.
Red Light this morning and the light
turned green and some dude just whizzed in
between me and some guy who
is about to change lanes.
So like I'm in this lane and I'm driving
straight and this guy was about to
change lanes.
This guy went and I went oh inches away.
I almost saw death.
I also saw a guy get killed and that
happens all day every day in la because
they're allowed to cut lanes. But here's
the thing, they assume risk. Yeah. Yup.
They assume all the worrying,
that thing where you're cutting lanes
and a guy turns into you and kills you.
It's their fault. It's on you.
Yup. It's crazy. Like in Chicago,
do you can't split lanes in Illinois.
You're not allowed to, but didn't appeal,
but there's no helmet law. I
seen that to me is like, man,
this shit's all these fucking
guys on Harleys. Fuck yeah.
Fucking helmets or feed up on the
the things not wearing a helmet.
I'm not some fun knowing,
not some faggy did push
the skin a head trauma.
They should just all be forced to
look at Gary Busey before and after.
You don't want to wear a fucking element.
Did him and I know you know he
hit a curb with his skull. Dude.
The fact that he's alive is insane.
Oh, the doctors, doctors this shit.
I just smothering him with a pillow.
You're good. We're going to take you out.
Dude. Pulled bastard. I was watching
some thing the other day with him.
Joe Really recently talking
and I was like, Whoa, it's
right to be here on Rogan.
Joe fucking love you man.
He's fucking breakable of
having like normal talk.
It's all like theatrical and
animated because I think years of,
I think years of of acting and stuff
late in his brain and now that he's got
kind,
Kinda like he's off the edge.
I think he feels like he has to be
a caricature to like feel normal.
You know what I mean?
I think he's the way he masks the
serious brain trauma and pain,
whatever pain is really going on.
I think that's it. Maybe it's fine.
Maybe a meet him and he's
like, Hey, I'm playing it up.
This is what I got. He said,
what do you mean this is a bit, it's my
thing. He's outside smoking a cigarette.
He goes, what are you guys talking
about? It's a fucking bit chill.
It's just me doing fucking try and
make a living. Just making money, man.
I'm trying to feel my fucking family
away cause fuck is wrong with you.
So I got one eye is like two
inches higher than the other one.
That's what he's got now.
It's above his eyebrow.
It's like where eyebrow it should
be. It's like way up here. Well he's,
Oh got caved in. I mean, and it was not
funny to laugh at it, but my God, it just,
he just looks, when you see
him when he's young, you know,
he's kind of like a normal looking dude
and like, okay look and dude and the,
now you're like Jesus Christ
and he's just all squirrely now.
But if you go back to him and like lethal
weapon, he was a bad motherfucker. Look,
look at his left eye's like down.
It's like shifted. Something's
wrong. Yeah. But when he was young,
like the lethal weapon, like when he
played Mr Joshua. Yeah. Fucking wicked.
I was awesome. I go to that one
picture with the two heads scroll.
Scroll down please.
None of these are Photoshop.
Go to that one picture with the
green lettering. Photoshop. Oh yeah.
Don't go to that. So a lot
of these hearings after
rude, that's just being rude.
Being an ass about the one on the right
hand side with the suit. The suit on
Deloitte below that with a suit. The
actual suit. That's a real photo player.
Just being silly.
Well this was back when helmet laws
didn't exist. Yeah, no helmet law.
You could ride around La with no
helmet if they should all be. I mean,
even if they're within the law, why
wouldn't you want to mean fuck me? I,
I get that. It's probably wait, I don't
listen to all the community is like,
you don't get it. Yeah Bro.
You don't understand. Freedom.
I like my fucking brain Caribou. Me? Yeah.
I like my, I like my brain. Sorry man.
I don't like, you know, but
there's a lot of states,
Arizona's and other one you see people
with no hell no helmet law. Yeah,
no helmet. Texas. I think Vegas
he allowed to have in Nevada.
I mean I've seen plenty of guys on bikes
without one, but I can't tell you who,
what cop would pull you over. You know
what I mean? It's kind of like in Vegas.
What do they do? The last thing on
their fucking mind are supposed to,
in Vegas you are look up
just Google states without
helmet laws and see how many
there are. Colorado. I know you don't
have to have one. Definitely seen people.
Wild country man. That's,
they don't give a fuck. Nope.
It's square state square style.
Perfectly Square man in 19
states that require it. Wow.
And three one, there is no motorcycle
helmet. You Slot in three states,
Illinois, Iowa, New Hampshire.
But says currently 19 states and
DC have laws requiring all writers.
So that's what the all writers,
both 19 states, all riders. Yeah.
But three states have no laws. Yeah,
yeah, Illinois. But what, but some states,
wait a minute, it's only three
states where you can wear no helmet.
What of those states? Illinois, Iowa and
New Hampshire. But in Chicago or Colorado,
maybe it's, maybe it's maybe the
law. It's new. Yeah. Wait a minute.
Is it just Google helmet laws in Colorado?
Motorcycle.
I've seen people ride motorcycles
in Colorado with no helmet.
The helmets are proven to save
lives and Colorado. However,
if the motorcycle operator passengers
are under 18 they must wear a helmet.
Passengers, yeah, that same passenger law,
but that's under 18 under 18 if they're
over 18 they can do whatever the fuck
they want. Is that what it says? What
it says. So there isn't a helmet law.
You just, if you're, if you're 18 or
if you're 16 they have helmet laws.
So what you're saying is three
states have no helmet laws.
That means under 18 over eight doesn't
matter. It doesn't matter. Right.
But some states have laws, but grown
ass adults can decide to go suicide,
but they won't style. And
yeah, that's where it is. Yeah.
That's fucking crazy weird. The people
that fight for that, they don't,
but that's like saying no seatbelt law.
That's the crazy thing. What do you don't?
You don't want to wear it,
but here's the thing,
like how is it okay to
ride a motorcycle ever?
And I have to have a seatbelt on. Yeah.
Like I'm inside a metal cage. Yes.
Motherfuckers that 3,500 pound cake,
a steering wheel,
and this motherfuckers just got
handlebars. He'd go fly him ad.
I'll get that shit. I don't know why you
wouldn't want to fucking wear helmet.
There's no, there's nothing to hold
you on. You're fucked. You get clipped.
You're done.